vsauce kevin here with a game so
complex and so important that it's the
basis for an entire
five-day course on strategic thinking
this is it that that's it
what is this welcome to the
l game developed by edward de bono over
50 years ago
the l game was designed to be the
simplest possible game that could
stretch the player's ability to find
not just any solution but the best
solution
in a constantly changing environment
here's how it works the l game only has
a handful of pieces a
very tiny board and hardly any rules and
it's deliberately
indeterminate meaning that two perfect
players could
theoretically play forever with no
winner and
there's a point to that let's look at
the board it's just a
four by four grid and each player has a
single
l-shaped piece that takes up four total
spaces there are also two neutral pieces
these
pennies that can be moved by either
player
and we start the game by nestling the
two l's in the center and putting the
neutral pennies in the top left and the
bottom right corners
so get ready to l each player is
required to move their
l piece into a new unoccupied spot
on the board by picking it up and moving
it
flipping it twisting it turning it
whatever as long as it cleanly occupies
four
squares so like this or like this
not like this or like
this it's you can't do that
that doesn't work as long as at least
one
square is new and it doesn't overlap
with the other l piece or a neutral spot
then the move is legal after that move
the player can choose to move
either neutral piece to an open space or
not it's totally up to you whether you
want to play
defense but you can't move the neutral
piece
before you move your l the only
object of the game is to make it so that
the other player can't move their
l piece if they can't move then you
win like if our pieces were in this
position
i could move my l here and the neutral
piece
here and i win your l is locked in
you can't go anywhere see
and that's it it's game over it seems so
easy so how can this game possibly take
five days
to master consider the following board
position which de bono uses in his 1967
book
five day course in thinking which is
actually three
five day courses the l game is just one
of them i'll be player one
pink and you'll be player two orange i
only have
three possible moves here uh let me show
you
it's not that difficult to choose one
right wrong
choosing a legal move is easy choosing
the best move
isn't i need to think about what's
likely to happen after i make
my move what will you do on the next
turn and
what kind of board position will you put
me in for my next move will you
play perfectly or will you make a
mistake that gives me
an advantage and if that's what i have
to consider to make the best move what
do
you need to think it seems
impossible to know and that difficulty
is at the heart of de bono's strategic
thinking you can employ a few basic
strategies to
survive and conquer like blocking off a
3x3 grid in the corner of a board using
your l
and a neutral piece and then
manipulating the other neutral piece to
eliminate your opponent's possible moves
or you can think about the grid as two
halves and lock your opponent
in one half of the grid
those strategies are pretty good but
they're far from perfect let's go back
to my earlier scenario
given my three possible moves you have
counter moves for each
counters a and b both result in a
loss for me because there's just nowhere
for me to put
my l because remember the neutral spot
can only be moved
after a player moves the l piece counter
move
c is my best possible move because i'm
not
locked in i don't automatically lose
with c
the trick is whether i can see
this coming in advance so that i can
avoid
taking the l all right
got three moves think ahead no
big deal but what if we have this
situation
this has 195
possible moves with only one of them
being the best that's one out of 195.
awesome given the confines of the board
there are 82
possible positions for the l pieces and
2 296 board states
all together de bono teaches that we
should learn
how to think about the l game by
mentally
ranking a move in one of four ways
fatal in which your opponent wins on the
next move
weak which leads you into a defensive
position
neutral which changes nothing for either
player and strong which gives you
the advantage in this board position
there are
65 possible moves 22
are fatal 17 are weak 26
neutral and zero strong
can you consider all those possibilities
and
keep track of them two or three moves
down the line perfect play entails
collecting and evaluating
every possible move and making the best
choice
based on those results which is
perfectly
impossible even for a human mind
obsessed
with tetraminos like
everyone modern humans love
tetrominos which are geometric shapes
made of
four equal squares joined edge to edge
there are five free tetrominos which are
the basic shapes you'll probably
recognize from tetris
the l square z line
and t and tetris also has two
chiralities of the
l and the z they can be shifted
rotated rejiggered or reflected to fit
all together like in this 5x8 grid which
is one
of 99 352
ways that these pieces can fit within
these boundaries or this 4x10 rectangle
which can be formed any of
57 472 ways using
tetrominos until minecraft tetris was
the number one selling game
of all time because our brains are
fascinated with geometry puzzles and
considering
the unknowns a few moves ahead
or one hundred thousand moves ahead
okay let's go back to l on
day three of training de bono says that
a player can note the positions that
made them lose
and the positions that made the other
player win
that mindset is simple you'll eventually
learn to avoid the bad spots and put
yourself
in the good spots experience matters and
it trains us
to think but it means it takes
time and you'll lose a lot of games
along the way
you need strategic principles and if you
want to play it yourself
i put a link down below to an online
version of the l game it'll show you how
many possible moves you have in each
board state and let you run
simulation after simulation to see just
how
complex this simple looking game really
is to make sense of the impossibility of
calculating
every possible move in real time de bono
advocates creating a set
of several guiding principles that can
inform
your strategy like always keeping a
neutral piece
adjacent to your l piece
or taking corner positions whenever
you can there aren't any magic
answers the possibilities here are
endless
but your strategic principles informed
by your experience are
essentially shortcuts to success
allowing you to
avoid playing 10 million l games or
considering
every single possible move the more you
play
and the better your mental grouping of
game situations develops the more
accurate your guiding strategic
principles will be
15 years after de bono's book came out
n e goaler devised a simple system that
will guarantee a player
at least an indefinite draw and provide
opportunities to win if their opponent
makes a mistake if you can get your lp
so that it occupies
three of the four central squares in the
grid
or so it occupies two central squares
and no
neutral piece occupies any of the
squares
marked x you're in good shape to not
lose beyond that it's up to you to use
your strategic thinking skills to win
the game
in an academic mathematical game you
could spend a few years working out all
the moves and ranking their utility but
in real life when you're sitting
across the table from the other player
just like you're sitting across the
table
from me you can't take forever you gotta
make a move and
the player who can accurately think the
furthest in advance
is going to win which is what we
all do every day in our own ways
in our own lives today
is another day in our never-ending
course
on strategic thinking we
don't rotate l's on a board but we do
envision the future and alter our
decisions in the present
to give ourselves the best opportunity
to succeed
we break down our life boards into
smaller more manageable sections and
create little systems based on what
we've learned and
what we've come to value we gain
experience and
make shortcuts to give us the optimal
chance
to avoid l's and
manifest w's
and as always thanks for watching
you